We're on our way to plotting the conditional means for
a to months. Remember we're trying to generate this plot again
but only for smaller bin widths. We'll have more data points
since age will be measured in months rather than in years.
Now that we've got our age with months variable from
before we can go ahead and use the d apply r
functions. To get a new data frame with an average friend
count. And the median friend count for each age with months.
So here comes your second programming task. Create a new
data frame called PF.FC by age months that contains the mean
friend count, the median friend count, and the number of
users in each group of age with months. There will be
detailed instructions on this on the next page. And an
example of what your output should look like. Now this is
one of the more challenging programming exercises. So if you get
stuck, check out the instructor notes for two hints. This exercise
will also be automatically graded and will check the output of your data frame.